I think YouTube shorts is very big for
this audience I'm obsessed with it
because it's search the amount of people
that search YouTube where they're
considering to move to a town is
staggering it's second behind Google I
know that I'm moving because my husband
or my wife is being relocated in a year
to Newton Massachusetts and literally
the second place people will type in
Newton Mass schools Newton Mass Parks
country clubs YouTube is number two and
if you're making YouTube short content
you're showing up in that especially if
you're smart on how you title if you'd
make a video and it's titled the school
systems in Newton Mass and your real
estate agent talking about the schools
in detail that becomes the reason you
get the lead